when you sat down to create that  beautiful simple  piano song you obviously knew the story  you knew what was going on how did you  how did you kind of decide on this  this melody well that one if i recall  correctly happened in the shower and not  at the piano  uh  that was what i had seen the movie and  i've been thinking about it and pete  doctor and i had a discussion and pete  was like it'd be great if it felt like  it was like a music box sort of a melody  that you could hear and yes and you  remember and it's just sort of like and  we also knew that we  wanted some sort of waltz that felt like  a couple's dance  um but i remember being in the shower  and that melody was in my head  and i remember thinking like oh i should  go write this down  and then i said to myself well  i'm not gonna write it down if i  remember this tomorrow  then maybe that's a good sign  [Music]  through the night you're shining bright  i'm your host  [Music]